nuestro objetivo es predecir si el plomo
2 positivo puede o no oxidar al aluminio
sólido o al cobre sólido bajo
condiciones estándar y calcular es 0 es
decir el potencial de celda estándar
verdad es 0 para cada reacción a 25
grados celsius así que tenemos una tabla
tenemos una tabla de potenciales de
reducción estándar verdad y es una
versión muy muy recortada de ella verdad
simplemente tenemos aquí algunas semi
reacciones escritas como si fueran semi
reacciones de reducción y que están
justamente del lado izquierdo y tenemos
los potenciales de reducción estándar
para dichas semi reacciones que tenemos
verdad y estos están medidos en bolsas
así que nuestra pregunta quiere saber si
el plomo puede oxidar o no estos metales
sólidos ok
queremos saber si el plomo puede oxidar
dichos metales sólidos así que el plomo
en realidad es el plomo 2 positivo está
funcionando como
agente oxidante verdad así que el mismo
debería estar siendo reducido verdad
pero está funcionando como un agente
oxidante vamos a ponerlo aquí que éste
está funcionando como un agente oxidante
y en general un agente oxidante puede
oxidar cualquier agente reductor verdad
que es que se encuentre por debajo en
nuestra tabla de potenciales de
reducción y si nos fijamos en la tabla
aquí tenemos el plomo 2 positivo verdad
y tenemos a nuestros agentes oxidantes
más fuertes yendo hacia arriba verdad
justamente lo que tenemos escrito del
lado izquierdo verdad y un agente
oxidante puede puede oxidar cualquier
agente reductor que se encuentre por
debajo en nuestra tabla así que si
encontramos el aluminio aquí aquí
tenemos el aluminio simplemente está
debajo del plomo verdad del plomo 2
positivo así que podemos predecir que el
plomo 2 positivo puede oxidar el
aluminio así que nuestra predicción es
que sí
y puede oxidar al aluminio ok de hecho
podemos dibujar una línea diagonal
digamos esta línea diagonal
que va del plomo 2 positivo al aluminio
y pre decimos que esto va a funcionar
verdad esta reacción va a funcionar
vamos a poner una palomita de que si va
a funcionar así que a veces algunas
ocasiones podrás ver que a este se le
conoce como la regla de la diagonal muy
bien así que vamos a predecir si es que
el plomo 2 positivo puede oxidar el el
cobre sólido y un agente oxidante no
puede oxidar a un agente reductor que
aparece por arriba de él en nuestra
tabla de potenciales de reducción
estándar así que si dibujamos ahora una
flecha que vaya del plomo 2 positivo al
cobre en este caso el agente reductor es
el cobre y se encuentra por arriba del
plomo 2 positivo así que podemos decir
que esto no va a funcionar muy bien así
que vamos a escribirlo vamos a anticipar
que esto no va a funcionar por supuesto
todo esto es bajo condiciones estándar
muy bien así que vamos a continuar y
calcular los potenciales de celda
estándar
para cada una de estas reacciones para
confirmar nuestras predicciones muy bien
así que vamos a empezar con el plomo 2
positivo que es que se encuentre
oxidando al aluminio sólido muy bien así
que si nos fijamos en el plomo 2
positivo entonces estaríamos pensando en
esta semi reacción está semi reacción
que tenemos aquí y vamos a dejarlo
simplemente como una semi reacción de
reducción muy bien así que nuestra semi
reacción de reducción sería plomo 2
positivo muy bien tenemos plomo 2
positivo que le agregamos 2 electrones y
nos da plomo sólido muy bien y además
sabemos que el potencial de reducción
estándar para esta semi reacción el
potencial estándar de para esta semi
reacción de reducción es de menos 0.13
volts muy bien así que esto es menos o
menos 30 puntos 13 volts es decir 0.13
negativo muy bien así que ahora vamos a
escribir la semi reacción
para el aluminio vamos a escribir la
semi reacción de oxidación para el
aluminio aquí tenemos justamente en esta
reacción el aluminio y vamos a tener que
escribir esta semi reacción como si
fuera bueno como una semi reacción de
oxidación así que tenemos que revertir
esta esta semi reacción que tenemos aquí
porque aquí se encuentra en una forma de
reducción así que simplemente escribimos
el aluminio sólido que nos produce
aluminio 3 positivo verdad aluminio 3
positivo +3 electrones es decir para
lograr esto necesitamos perder esos 3
electrones y la pérdida de electrones
significa óxidos y oxidación así que
necesitamos encontrar el potencial de
oxidación estándar para esta semi
reacción y ya lo hemos hecho esto varias
ocasiones verdad simplemente hay que
revertir el signo del potencial de
reducción que teníamos anteriormente
verdad porque hemos revertido la
reacción así que el potencial de
oxidación sera
simplemente 11.66 pero con el signo
contrario así que sería positivo 1.66
volts muy bien entonces lo que hicimos
fue este número que tenemos aquí
cambiarle el signo porque no
consideramos la reacción inversa muy
bien ahora si quisiéramos escribir la
reacción digamos completa o la reacción
total en primera instancia necesitamos
balancear absolutamente todo verdad así
que necesitamos obtener el mismo número
de electrones así que esto lo podríamos
conseguir simplemente multiplicando esta
primera reacción por 3 verdad si
multiplicamos por 3 digamos a estos dos
electrones obtendremos simplemente 6
electrones para esta primera semi
reacción muy bien pero el número de
electrones tiene que ser exactamente el
mismo así que necesitamos multiplicar
esta segunda esta segunda semi reacción
por 2 de tal suerte que 2
por 3 electrones nos de nuevamente 6
electrones así que vamos a hacer esas
cuentas digamos un poquito más abajo
para la primera semi reacción tendremos
digamos para la semi reacción de
reducción tendremos tres plomo 2
positivo 3 plomo 2 positivo más 6
electrones nos va a dar 3 plomos sólidos
muy bien ahora para la segunda reacción
tendremos la red la semi reacción de
oxidación que sería 2 aluminios sólidos
que nos produce 2 aluminios 3 positivo 3
2 aluminios 3 positivos más 6 electrones
ahora si pensamos en los potenciales de
reducción y de oxidación por ejemplo
pensemos en el potencial de reducción
para esta primera semi reacción
recordemos que en realidad el valor no
cambia verdad porque el voltaje es una
propiedad intensiva así que dejamos
nuestro potencial de reducción estándar
como
- 0.13 volts es decir 0.13 negativo y lo
mismo ocurre para el potencial de
oxidación verdad como es una es una
propiedad como el voltaje es una
propiedad intensiva simplemente quedaría
como 1.66 volts positivos así que para
obtener la reacción total la reacción
completa digamos simplemente tenemos que
sumar digamos
estas dos reacciones verdad así que para
obtener la reacción total sumamos perdón
estas dos semi reacciones y lo que
podemos observar inmediatamente es que
podemos cancelar ahora si nuestros
electrones verdad tenemos la misma
cantidad de electrones de ambos lados y
del lado izquierdo obtendremos tres
plomo 2 positivo que le agregamos 2
alumni
sólidos y esto nos produce tres plomos
sólidos más dos aluminios tres positivos
muy bien y aquí tendríamos nuestra
reacción total ahora si quisiéramos
calcular el potencial el potencial de
celda verdad tendríamos que calcular el
potencial de celda estándar esto
simplemente sería la suma de los dos
potenciales que ya teníamos la suma de
el potencial de reducción más el
potencial de oxidación muy bien entonces
si hacemos esto el potencial de celda
sería sumar sería sumar menos 0.13
verdad sería el potencial de reducción
estándar más 1.66 que sería el potencial
estándar de oxidación y por lo tanto
podemos concluir que el potencial es tan
el potencial de celda estándar sería 1
punto 53 volts verdad 1.53 volts y hay
que hacer explícito que es positivo
verdad y recordemos que cuando nuestro
potencial de celda es positivo esto
significa que tenemos una reacción
espontánea así que aquí tenemos una
reacción espontánea que era justo lo que
habíamos predicho verdad nosotros
hicimos la predicción de que el plomo 2
positivo si va a poder oxidar el
aluminio verdad así que aquí es lo
justamente lo que habíamos predicho
habíamos dicho que si utilizando la
regla de la diagonal simplemente
dibujando esta flecha y ahora que hemos
calculado el potencial es de ese el de
estándar también hemos visto que que
nuestra predicción era cierta verdad
ahora vamos a hacer el caso del cobre
verdad ya hemos dicho que el plomo dos
positivos no va a ser capaz de oxidar el
cobre verdad ahora vamos a intentar
confirmar esto calculando el potencial
de celda estándar para
nuestra predicción así que vamos a
considerar esta misma semilla reacción
que tenemos aquí verdad esta es la misma
que utiliza el plomo 2 positivo y
también vamos a considerar esta otra
semi reacción verdad pero vamos a tener
que considerarla en digamos en dirección
contraria verdad y cuando consideramos
la directa de la reacción en dirección
contraria tenemos que cambiar el signo
de nuestro potencial de reducción muy
bien así que vamos a hacer esto
regresemos abajo donde teníamos mucho
espacio para hacer todo esto y empecemos
colocando la semi reacción de reducción
que simplemente sería el plomo dos
positivos cierto al cual le agregamos
dos electrones y esto nos da plomo
sólido muy bien ahora bien para la semi
reacción de oxidación nosotros
consideramos la reacción la semi
reacción contraria verdad sería el cobre
sólido que nos produce
2 positivo sobre 2 positivo y además los
electrones verdad está justamente
perdiendo electrones ahora bien los
potenciales de reducción el potencial de
reducción estándar para la primera
reacción era justamente menos 0.13 si
así es es menos 0.13 aquí tendremos
menos 0.13 mientras que el potencial
estándar de oxidación era el que
teníamos en esta semi reacción de
reducción pero con el signo contrario
verdad entonces sería menos 0.34 así que
para encontrar la reacción completa lo
único que tenemos que hacer es sumar
estas dos semi reacciones para encontrar
la reacción total o completa y de hecho
en este caso ya tenemos el mismo número
de electrones verdad así que estos se
cancelan y colocamos primero los
reactivos verdad que serían estos que
tenemos aquí y sería
2 positivo más cobre sólido eso nos
produce nuestros productos verdad que en
este caso serían plomo sólido y cobre 2
positivo entonces lo anotamos sería
sería plomo sólido más cobre 2 positivo
muy bien y aquí ya tenemos nuestra
reacción total ahora si calculamos el
potencial de es el de estándar tenemos
que encontrar tenemos que encontrarlo
simplemente sumando el potencial de
reducción estándar y el potencial de
oxidación estándar así que esto sería el
potencial de celda estándar sería menos
0.13 menos 0.13 más o bueno si le
sumamos menos 0.34 y de una vez vamos a
poner el resultado porque eso es muy
fácil de calcular sería menos 0.47 volts
muy bien nuestro potencial de celda
estándar sería menos 0.47 volts y
entonces para esta reacción hemos
obtenido que el potencial de es el de
estándar es negativo y sabemos que
cuando esto ocurre no
es una reacción espontánea muy bien
entonces esta no es una reacción
espontánea no es una reacción espontánea
verdad simplemente porque hemos
calculado el potencial de celda estándar
y es negativo de hecho si calcularemos
por ejemplo el cambio estándar en la
energía libre verdad como el potencial
de celda estándar es negativo entonces
tendríamos que el cambio en la energía y
el cambio si el cambio de la energía
libre sería de valor positivo verdad y
cuando tenemos un valor positivo en el
cambio en la energía libre entonces no
es una reacción espontánea así que vamos
a arriba vamos a arriba en donde
habíamos planteado nuestro problema y
podemos ver que hemos confirmado nuestra
predicción verdad de que el plomo 2
positivo no iba a oxidar el cobre sólido
verdad esta no es una reacción
espontánea así que el aluminio el
aluminio es más fácilmente oxidado
porque el cobre es cierto así que
podrías ver cómo funciona
utilizando este ejemplo utilizando
digamos la regla de la diagonal o
podrías calcular digamos el potencial de
celda estándar muy bien podríamos ver
que por ejemplo el aluminio que tenemos
justamente aquí aquí tenemos nuestro
aluminio el aluminio tiene un valor más
negativo para el el potencial de
reducción estándar y de ahí que es más
fácilmente oxidado verdad así que el
aluminio es más fácilmente oxidado que
el cobre y por eso es que decimos que el
aluminio es más activo déjenme
escribirlo aquí el aluminio es más
activo más activo que el cobre que el
cobre así que si recuerdas digamos la
serie de actividades o bueno puedes
explicar la serie de actividades que
tenemos en química general simplemente
fijándonos en los potenciales de
reducción estándar